so this is a surreal moment for me
because literally like Cyclops is my
childhood hero by far it's crazy to me
so I gotta ask us I know earlier this
week or the real thing was this week
Patrick Stewart came out said he met
with Kevin Feige about possibly
reprising the role of Professor Xavier
have you talked to Marvel or would you
even be up to reprise the role of
Cyclops again
great question I mean I look at those
three movies I was in and it was a it
became a huge part of my life it was a
family all of them and it was I was very
grateful to like that's 40 years at the
time of backstory and iconic characters
beloved characters and so I'd be a fool
to say no to that of course I would so
who knows where that universe goes
Feige is still a friend of mine and and
we talked occasionally but it's you just
don't know where it's gonna go right now
it's with all the youngsters right and
all the kiddos but I would would never
be opposed to coming back to that but I
hold a special place in my heart for
that experience how's it going everybody
it's Warren welcome back to the channel
ever since Kevin Feige announced at San
Diego comic-con of 2019 that the x-men
or mutants are going to be coming to the
MCU everybody has been asking the
question when and luckily for us it
doesn't look like it's going to be that
long in fact we could even see the first
mutant as early on as phase 4 we have a
lot of reports to go over about the
x-men in the MCU and Kevin Feige himself
has even commented on the future of the
x-men and Avengers and their team-up
film that is eventually going to happen
and not to mention that we could be seen
some of the original x-men from the
original x-men film in 2000 and of
course new x-men make an appearance in
phase 4 including Professor X by Patrick
Stewart Wolverine of course and Cyclops
as you just saw in the opening clip of
this video because Marvel just has huge
plans for phase 4 and specifically
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness and of course huge plans for
introducing the x-men to the MCU and the
New Avengers team in the MCU and then
bringing them together so we'll talk
about what Kevin Feige said about the
x-men and the avengers eventually
getting together as one team and break
down a couple of reports that say the
x-men are coming to the MCU soon if
you're new be sure to subscribe the
notifications turned on for your chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 I'm picking
a winner at 550,000 subscribe
so first let's talk about what Kevin
Feige said about the x-men and The
Avengers eventually teaming up we know
that he talked about the mutants coming
to the MCU at San Diego comic-con but he
actually talked about the mutants just a
few months ago in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter and in this interview
he was asked about the x-men appearing
in the MCU of course that's all anybody
really wants to know right now but in
this interview he was asked a very
specific question in regards to the New
Avengers that will eventually appear in
the MCU and the x-men coming together
the interviewer asked is there any
reason to believe that the x-men would
not be integrated with the Avengers and
these characters as well at some point
and Kevin Feige replied no no reason to
believe that confirming that the x-men
and the Avengers are going to be on the
same team in fact looking at the way
that the MCU is currently going there's
no doubt that some of these new mutants
that are going to be entering the MCU
could actually be a part of the New
Avengers team not having two teams
combining the x-men team and the
Avengers team but some x-men actually
being a part of this original New
Avengers team that's going to be formed
in the MCU because there's actually a
really good chance that Marvel isn't
just going to come out with an x-men
film they're most likely going to
introduce the x-men individually in solo
films or group films but not their own
x-men films because remember that's what
Fox did yeah they had a few solo movies
thrown in there but they weren't really
that successful what was really working
for Fox at least originally was having
big x-men films with all of the x-men in
one film and Kevin Feige has already
went on record during an interview and
said yes our x-men are going to be very
different versions than what the Fox
x-men were so don't expect there to be a
big x-men movie to start off the x-men
in the MCU they're most likely going to
be introduced gradually and just like
the individual Avengers were built up in
the first ten years of the MCU to
eventually become the Avengers and then
eventually we got Avengers in game
that's what they're going to do for the
mutants now introduce them one at a time
or two at a time or a few at a time but
not all together and eventually they'll
all just build up over the years - a big
x-men movie and this is pretty much all
but confirmed because we do have
confirmation from actors who have
confirmed they've met with Kevin Feige
about playing the role of an x-men in
the end
to you in phase four Patrick Stewart who
of course plays professor X in the
original x-men 2000 film and of course
some of the films that have followed as
well revealed and confirmed that he did
in fact meet with Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige about reprising
his role as Charles Xavier in an
interview about this he said I met with
Kevin Feige a couple of months ago and
we had long long conversations and there
have been moves and suggestions which
include Charles Xavier now ultimately
Patrick Stewart went on to say that he
does not think he's going to be
reprising his role as Charles Xavier
because he put that role to rest and
said goodbye to that role after Logan
now that doesn't necessarily mean that
he won't reprise his role but it's not
very likely but there is still a
possibility that Patrick Stewart and
even Hugh Jackman could make a small
cameo in Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness there was a report
by the Twitter account smart Tom that
the reason Patrick Stewart met with
Kevin Feige was for a cameo in
multiverse of madness with Wolverine
these cameos were supposedly for a quick
scene in which Doctor Strange opens up a
portal to the wrong place when he opens
up the portal he sees Professor Xavier
and right before he closes it wolverine
comes out in the background and asked if
he's talking to himself again so just a
quick little scene that would have
Professor X and Wolverine
technically be a part of the MCU but
Patrick Stewart meeting with Marvel
Studios about reprising the role as
Charles Xavier that does confirm that
the mutants are heading to the MCU soon
Patrick Stewart met with Kevin Feige
only a few months ago so that's most
likely not about anything too far out
phase 4 technically hasn't even begun
yet and once it does finally begin we
have two years until phase five so
there's a good possibility that we might
begin to see some x-men in the MCU as
early on as phase four and again the
most likely option is Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness Mikey Sutton
reported a month or so ago that the
Illuminati are set to make their MCU
debut in multiverse of madness and
according to Mikey not only will the
Illuminati introduce Namor and mr.
fantastic but Professor X as well so
it's confirmed that Patrick Stewart met
with Kevin Feige and if this report by
smart Tom ends up being true it's likely
that dr. strange was searching for
Professor X but he opened up the wrong
portal and got the wrong Professor X if
Marvel Studios ends up going
this way this means that both the x-men
and the Fantastic Four it won't be
introduced in one big film instead
they'll tease them a little bit before
they get their own films
now the Fantastic Four only are a group
of four of course so it's a little bit
easier to do one big film for them but
still having mr. fantastic introduced in
the Illuminati before making the big
Fantastic Four debut just makes a lot of
sense because this seems to be the route
that dr. strange and the multiverse of
madness is going to go with all of its
alternate realities and now that Marvel
Studios has Sam Raimi on board to direct
multiverse of madness it's very possible
that we're most likely going to see
alternate versions of different
characters that we know and love one of
course being Tobey Maguire spider-man
fingers crossed
so Doctor Strange to really is going to
be a huge huge movie bigger than most
people realize but we also have another
report from Mikey Sutton that says rogue
is actually going to be introduced in
Captain Marvel 2 now Captain Marvel 2 is
said to be coming in 2022 which means
they really are going to take their time
to build up individual x-men characters
over time until they have their big
movie now rogue and Captain Marvel 2 is
a perfect choice rogue and Captain
Marvel have a very long history together
in the comics and when rogue absorbs
Captain Marvel's powers she's one of the
most powerful mutants there is and not
to mention that rogue being the main
villain of Captain Marvel 2 could even
introduce the Brotherhood of mutants and
not to mention we even have the fact
that it's been confirmed that Emily
Blunt has met with Marvel Studios while
filming her Disney movie Jungle Cruise
with the rock she had a meeting with
Marvel which is pretty easy because
Disney does own Marvel Studios and she
met with them about a role in an
upcoming project
now again Marvel Studios isn't going to
be meeting with actors to cast them five
years down the road and then we have her
husband John Krasinski he has also
expressed interest in playing mr.
fantastic now everybody wants Emily
Blunt and her husband John Krasinski to
play mr. fantastic and The Invisible
Woman of the Fantastic Four however
there are many x-men that they would
just be perfect for in fact many fans
have stated that they wouldn't mind if
Emily Blunt played Jean Grey and John
Krasinski played Cyclops so it is very
possible that Emily Blunt although
everybody would really prefer her to
play Sue Storm The Invisible Woman it's
still possible that she has met with
Marvel Studios to play
x-men so the path of the Avengers and
the MCU is sort of like the New Avengers
they're going to gradually be introduced
until they're built up to be a team and
Kevin Feige has already confirmed that
we are going to see the x-men with the
Avengers and since we know that the New
Avengers team is going to start to be
built in phase four and it seems like
the x-men are starting to be built in
phase four as well it looks like we
could see this New Avengers x-men team
that Kevin Feige confirmed as early on
as phase five if they put it as the
final movie of phase five that would be
about four to five years away which
would be plenty of time after avengers
endgame plus would be totally and
completely different if you added the
x-men and the Fantastic Four to the
Avengers team which of course is
confirmed to happen by Kevin Feige so
the big team-up film with some x-men and
The Avengers could happen a lot sooner
than we actually think this team up
movie isn't going to be the last film of
the new infinity saga so to speak of the
next 10 years it's going to be about
halfway in most likely at the end of
phase 5 so let me know what you think
about this do you like the idea of the
x-men being built up gradually to
eventually have their own big film or
would you rather them just have an x-men
film to introduce them all let me know
what you think in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and notifications turned on so
you could stay up to date with
everything relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 the winner
will be chosen at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers don't forget to
join my discord if you want to talk with
fellow Marvel lovers and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof